for the last 16 years two men have been
in prison for exactly the same crime 42
year old Christian Pacheco spent 25
years behind bars after he was convicted
of cutting a man's throat in a new york
bar now another man confessed a decade
and a half ago but Pacheco was only
released last week our lead national
correspondent David Beck no spoke to
Pacheco who is now suing the state of
New York for over a hundred million
dollars when you look at the numbers
that's over half of his life David why
did it take so long while prosecutors
didn't have the new information until
after he was convicted and then sent to
prison based on the testimony of one man
who was later found to be unreliable so
what caused prosecutors to finally take
a second look at the case the person who
cut the victims throat confessed Pacheco
was a member of the Latin Kings gang at
the time of a murder in Brooklyn he was
at the scene of the crime but always
insisted he did not do what he was
accused of doing federal prosecutors in
New York City knew as far back as 1998
that someone had come forward to say
Cristian Pacheco was innocent of the
crime that sent him to prison
Melvin Garcia ended up being convicted
in 2004 of the same crime cutting the
throat of lineal crews when you found
out that someone had said I'm the guy I
did it and pleaded guilty what did you
think I believe in my heart I was gonna
come home so he was just a matter of
days probably months and that never
happened Pacheco was convicted in 1996
on the testimony of one person the bars
bouncer a former gang member
according to the prosecutors office two
years later other gang members came
forward to give their account of the
deadly night and they named Garcia as
the murderer and what year was that that
you were in prison that you found out he
pleaded guilty
I believe I knew Obama in somewhere in
1999 I knew that there were they will
they have gotten arrested for some
charges in the faith and somehow my case
had to do with those charges but then
you serve almost one
two more years melvin garcia was
eventually arrested during a federal
investigation into the Latin Kings gang
in 2005 Garcia told federal prosecutors
quote Christian Pacheco did not
participate in the murder but it was
still another 15 years before Pacheco
would be freed you know and that's a
flaw of the system criminal defense
attorney Kim Belkin says wrongful
convictions are very difficult to
overturn if you're the DA do you really
want to go questioning the people that
you rely on to prosecute cases they sort
of have this wall of silence where they
say hey we're all on the same team
whatever happened happened Pacheco's
conviction was vacated and his
indictment was dismissed last week he
walked out of prison a free man
for the first time in nearly 25 years
does the freedom feel foreign to you I'm
not gonna say it feels foreign cuz I
always believed that I was gonna get it
back I feel peace because I was able to
prove my innocence
twice Pacheco was offered a plea deal
and he said no I won't take you because
I didn't do it the Brooklyn da has made
it clear that he does believe Pacheco is
not completely innocent they say mr.
Pacheco did stab the victim but they
admit it was Melvin Garcia who dealt a
fatal blow 25 years in prison and
knowing that somebody else had confessed
to it it's a little murky when you hear
the part about stabbing the victim but
even if everybody confessed to say that
he didn't do that right didn't kill the
man and they had that evidence at the
time right now it was interesting
yesterday when I met him he was sitting
in an office behind some glass and he
was just sitting there like this with
his food on his lap and he wasn't moving
yeah and it occurred to me it still
feels like a cell that he later said
this office is bigger than my jail cell
so he's getting used to like hey walk
around when I want I don't have to stay
in this house I can write a thing he was
offered a plea deal and didn't take it
did not know twice that's it I'm not
doing got him to write write write he's
out all right David thank you very much